now talk to me about um
proof of work proof of stake i know that
there's a ton of debate we just saw the
european union obviously uh voted on and
ended up deciding not to ban uh proof of
work we just had on
a member uh of space force who also is a
national defense uh fellow at mit who
was talking about the ideas of a
decentralized network is actually a form
of a weapon system and could be
incredibly impactful uh for the united
states or other countries
how do you just sift through this right
and
if you have specific views and you say
hey look you know i feel educated enough
to have an opinion great if you're kind
of still working through it just like
how do you think about uh kind of
filtering proof of work proof of stake
and how the united states should act
here yeah
well i know i know some of the bitcoin
max was that as a matter of prediction
think that it's going to be the proof of
work because that's ultimately the most
decentralized and no individual
has control and uh of course the the
founder it may not no longer be uh
alive or no longer be uh in control and
so uh i understand that's their
perspective folks
proof of stake say well
the proof of uh work is too time
consuming and inefficient the proof of
stake is is better uh and they raise of
course the energy concerns though
someone told me that the entire bitcoin
mining takes less than 0.1 of global
energy uh and a lot of that frankly can
be done through demand response and you
don't have to be near the energy center
to do it and a lot of it can be clean
energy so i think there's solutions to
that and then i was talking to the
founder of solana and he said he has a
third concept of a different type of
proof that he's introducing i guess my
view of it as a lawmaker is i don't have
to take a position for or against one of
these how could i i mean even people in
the industry don't know uh i'm for sort
of a pluralistic approach but what i
want to make sure is that we don't uh
sort of demonize proof of work uh as
some have done and that uh that the
government be uh recognize that you can
have uh clean mining and you can have uh
solutions to that and then let's see
what the market and people want yeah i
think it's a very nuanced perspective of
just hey
uh allow the free market to determine
the winner a lot of the technologists uh
and kind of the the end users to
determine what ends up having value
rather than the politicians which uh is
hard right like there is an element of
uh when you're in the business of having
to take a side or having to have an
opinion because there's votes and and
various legislation gets put forward uh
i don't envy you or your colleagues and
uh and always having to understand and
vote on things but that's just the
nature of the job it seems
it is a nature of the job but where
you're dealing with such complex
technology that's still in its incipient
stage i think we can take a view that we
don't know everything and then it would
be uh highly problematic i mean i don't
say this with any sense of arrogance but
i probably know more about bitcoin and
crypto than 95 of other members of
congress and i don't feel in any way
qualified to be making a decision about
what uh what is going to emerge as as
dominant between proof-of-work proof of
stake so it would be responsible for
congress to be so definitive and uh i i
like to to make sure that we have a sort
of different pluralistic approach let's
see what emerges and then be honest
about what the advantages and
disadvantages may be of each approach uh
and also uh to to refute some of the uh
unfair attacks on the approaches yeah
that this uh perspective that you're
presenting reminds me a lot of the book
that you recently uh wrote which is
dignity in the digital age making tech
work for all of us and this idea that uh
some people adopt technologies and other
times we need to bring technology to
certain groups certain types of people
or certain applications talk to me a
little bit about some of the the large
ideas in the book and why you know given
everything else you have going on and
and uh obviously the not busy life that
you have why did you want to write the
book
well look we have 11 trillion dollars in
my district in the surrounding areas
it's the most wealth created in human
history apple google intel yahoo cisco
linkedin
and i said in the 21st century our
challenge is to decentralize wealth
generation we need a lot of the
communities in rural america the midwest
and black and brown communities to have
the opportunity to build wealth to have
digital jobs to start companies uh to
participate so they don't have to leave
their hometown
to succeed and
the book is all about the
decentralization of technology and how
do we get
more people uh participating in these 25
million digital jobs that's why i think
as a progressive that we should be
celebrating uh what blockchain and
crypto represent it's all about
decentralization away from the power of
the banks away from the power of the
biggest tech companies and saying we can
actually decentralize the opportunity to
participate to build companies through
tokens uh we can decentralize who gets
to participate uh in wealth generation
because most of the ipos and investment
and technology are closed to a very few
set of accredited investors this is
the crypto is far more uh open uh and we
may be able to skip the middlemen we may
be able to actually uh especially be
able to remit uh money and move money
without western union fees so i knew the
whole thing is democratizing uh
obviously there has to be smart
regulation and there has to be the
appropriate tax and we need to make sure
that there's compliance and we need to
make sure there's not wild speculation
but what i don't understand is people
who come at it with a fear of a
technology that's fundamentally shifting
power away uh from concentration and
empowering individuals hey you did you
like this video great we make five of
them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time